hallo leute und herzlich willkommen zum
besten video wahrscheinlich habt ihr
noch niedrigen video gesehen wo einfach
ein junger mann kommt nun eine idee hat
es an ideen einfach investierten
arbeitet und am ende die umsetzung
bewerten das video heute ist nicht so
eins aber wir fangen trotzdem an
ich bin übrigens rat in amsterdam ging
dem hintergrund verfügung hat ich habe
letztens mit freunden gefragt ja es
wurde immer später und die konversation
wurde sinnloser und irgendwann wenn ich
auf die glorreiche idee gekommen was ich
sagen will über die sprachausgabe von
google zu sagen das klingt dann in etwa
so ja und ich meine es war eigentlich
erst so spät war aber eigentlich ist
foto stick und ich werde jetzt ganz
viele youtube ein whatsapp renk spielen
in irgendwelche dummen nachrichten mit
dieser sprache schicken
als erstes du stress moral als erstes
schicke ich natürlich meine luca eine
sprachmemos und was schreiben
ich habe mir was sehr gut ist überlegt
also ich muss euch nochmal erinnern
berechnet nicht gut was wirklich lustige
vereinigt ist überhaupt nicht lustig
hallo du bist ertragskraft
darauf antwortet luca beweis erstmal
hashtag fake news münchen spricht der
präsident von der ganzen welt kann graf
daher bereich und mäder lol recht passen
sie sich einen anderen planeten
damit hat jetzt erst mal was zu können
du kannst auf die nachrichten vom
präsidenten mit
ist der verrückt hält der präsident hat
doch zu ihm gesprochen
so kann man guckt mal bei facebook das
video
[Musik]
das sind super glücklich in genau dem
moment auch im alter fit werde ich die
richtige computerstimmen menschen
geschickt kelly lance net germany
faktoren verliert und luca nicht luca
willen battle lukaschik dem battle und
jetzt leute kommt der komplette
finishing move und zwar schlicht die
sprache auf englisch aber sagt trotzdem
teilweise was deutschen blue kann ihm da
zu gehen das was als nächstes nehmen wir
sie bitte hör zu ich glaube das sind die
gekränkten personen lustiger als wenn
man eine mod sap rang oder sowas macht
ich meine ich ist das was der punkt weil
ich hab da einen kontext auf wasser
geschickt beantwortet
eine andere position vielleicht über den
mänteln
danke für diese antwort ich habe ihm das
hier geschickt jetzt würde ich komplett
mit triebes geistigen wohlbefinden
spielen das ist in ordnung
fahrzeugstudien wirklich sowas hat mir
noch niemand gewachsen dass dann auch
noch du der dafür bekannt ist dass er
eigentlich sind ein sehr liebevoller
mensch ist mir zutiefst schickt wenn
auch meine sprachmemos lassen hat ja
jetzt kürzlich wie gehabt mit mega pablo
deshalb müssen wir mal was passendes
überlegen ich brauche jetzt sterbe hier
von justin habe ich schon die allererste
aktions was kommt jetzt kommt ein
fashion ende küche ich lasse meine
erklärung macht sind die ideen
ausgegangen so dass er jetzt
sprachnachrichten google translate an
seine youtube freund geschickt
[Musik]
klassen antwortet zusätzlichen robotern
ersetzt wurde
nein dann ist mein kampf verglich kranke
abonnieren mich alle harlow ja da war
ich endlich meine speicherkarte voll und
mit vollem einig natürlich voll mit
guten content ist werde ich auch ganz
lustig wenn ich mein manager in sorge um
ein persönliches wohl bringen würde
das macht das jetzt einfach mal keine
besorgten nachricht zurück kommt aber
diesmal aus
hallo liebe nicht suchen wir einen
anderen namen siri den wir antworten
jetzt natürlich mikro kann shop war ein
schock ich war da nicht mal hellwach
scheiß auf dem weg in eine gerade neuen
erzeugnis mal
meine freundin fragt mich gerade was ich
für ein video machte ich glaube es
erklären wir jetzt auch mal
ich mache ein video wo ich einfach nur
blumen im leben und mit einer
computerstimme an einer schicken hahaha
ich glaub jetzt können wir vielleicht
wirklich gut verarschen
hallo ich habe deine telefonnummer
überweisen effekt millionen 30 oder
sterbe h
bitte gebt ihm video jetzt nicht mehr
und nicht weniger als fünf millionen
30 live 34 leicht wie reagiert vertritt
ob meine drohen auf dem video nicht
produktiver und der ist nicht auf sein
gefallen
jetzt will ich ja noch mal - du dem text
von 1 millionen von catherine barber
health basics für pah aber immer noch
der berliner schlafen ja und alle
anderen gehen um mike und ich habe spaß
an dem scheiß
okay das war's